avec le confinement beaucoup de
personnes ont souffert de solitude
ce qui peut favoriser la dépression et
diminuer les défenses immunitaires
mais des études indiquent que la
solitude pourraient aussi modifier le
fonctionnement du cerveau
confinement 40 l isolement
ces mots font désormais partie de nos
vies et ils mènent tous aux mêmes
sentiments la solitude pour des millions
de gens c'est devenu leur quotidien on
parle même d'une pandémie de solitude et
avec le recul on sait maintenant que cet
isolement laisse des conséquences bien
réelles sur notre cerveau
[Musique]
je me suis mis à parcourir les rues de
montréal et je prenais des photos de
gens qui étaient seuls photographes
amateurs
jacob mahfoud a voulu capturer en images
cette solitude en voyant ces gens là
seuls dans la rue mais ça me rappelait
moi même comme bien des gens il vit seul
et travaille de chez lui
jacobs aime sortir jouer au théâtre
rencontrer des amis mais depuis un an il
est forcé de passer la majorité de son
temps seul c'était la chose la plus dure
se sentir isolé et juste impuissants et
incapables de faire quoi que ce soit par
rapport à la situation à travers le
monde
des chercheurs ont voulu savoir comment
cette solitude affecte notre cerveau les
gens qui vivent de la solitude chronique
tendent à avoir plus de problèmes de
santé physique et mentale
ils souffrent plus d'hypertension ils
ont même un taux de mortalité plus élevé
cela suggère que d'être avec les autres
est nécessaire à notre survie
pour le démontrer
la chercheuse les viets me va a comparé
chez des individus deux besoins
fondamentaux celui de manger et celui
d'être en contact avec les autres nous
avons demandé aux participants de passer
une journée sans contact social au
laboratoire puis nous avons scanné leur
cerveau pendant qu'il regardait des
photos de leurs activités sociales
préférées ensuite ils ont jeûné pendant
une journée et nous avons observé leur
cerveau pendant qu'il regardait des
photos de nourriture voici le cerveau
d'une personne qui a faim et voici celui
d'une personne isolée
ils ont une certaine zone d'activation
en commun dont la substantia nigra ou
substance noire
composé de neurones c'est la principale
zone de production de dopamine dans le
cerveau cette hormone nous pousse à
rechercher des récompenses
[Musique]
c'est le centre du système de motivation
cette région du cerveau répond de façon
similaire aux jeunes et à l' isolement
et donc il semble que de passer même 10
heures sans contact avec les autres a le
même effet sur notre cerveau que si nous
avions été à jeun pendant dix heures ce
nous dit que la faim et la solitude
partagent une signature neuronale
similaire dans le service en d'autres
mots notre cerveau à un appétit pour le
contact social de la même façon qu'il a
un appétit pour la nourriture
c'est un peu ce que jacob a ressenti
avant je ne disais rien aux gens que je
ne connaissais pas dans la rue mais là
on a l'impression qui a toujours un
réflexe d'aller vers l'autre d'ouvrir
une petite discussion même des gens que
je connais pas tu vois mais parfois l
isolement se prolonge et cet appétit ne
peut être assouvie annonce nous savons
que si des animaux sont isolés trop
longtemps un mécanisme de compensation
se produit ils ont tendance soit à
manger plus soit abusé d'autres
récompenses
par contre on ne sait pas encore si ça
s'applique à lui même
mais une chose est sûre nous avons
besoin de compenser l'absence de contact
social
alors que se passe-t-il dans notre
cerveau quand la solitude se prolonge le
chercheur montréalais nuyten spring a
voulu répondre à cette question nous
savions qu'il y aurait un impact sur le
cerveau en tant que conséquence de la
solitude prenant place
à partir d'une banque d'informations
biologiques appelé uk bayod bang le
chercheur a eu accès aux scans de
cerveau de quarante mille individus
ainsi qu'à des informations sur leur
état mental
les participantes qui se sent seul ont
tous un point en commun et mobile free
unique
c'est vraiment une découverte unique en
neuroscience cognitive qui n'étaient pas
prêts dit par la littérature
scientifique
plusieurs zones de leur cerveau sont
sollicités simultanément ces zones
constituent ce que l'on appelle le
réseau par défaut ce réseau s'activent
lorsqu'on laisse libre cours à nos
pensées le réseau par défaut est très
impliquée dans la mémoire
autobiographique et l'imagination
on imagine à quoi va ressembler notre
avenir chez les gens seuls les
connexions dans ce réseau sont plus
solides et les neurones qui composent la
matière grise
ils sont plus nombreux leurs pensées se
tournent vers le monde social dont ils
sont privés
à force de se remémorer des contacts
sociaux
cela renforce le réseau par défaut de
leur cerveau
[Musique]
jacob a été happé par cette nostalgie
c'est comme si je faisais un voyage
constant dans le passé on dirait que
l'effort que mon cerveau fusée pour
reconstruire les souvenirs spécialement
des souvenirs d'enfance était énorme se
tourner vers ses souvenirs permet
d'oublier la solitude mais cela un tri à
long terme la solitude chronique comme
ce que l'on vit durant une pandémie fait
en sorte que ces connexions neuronales
se renforce alors un risque pour les
personnes âgées de développer de la za
meurent car la maladie peut se propager
plus rapidement à travers ce réseau le
sentiment de solitude a donc des
conséquences inquiétantes sur notre
santé cognitive
mais ses effets sont ils permanent
[Musique]
pour la plupart des gens seuls nous
pensons que le cerveau peut revenir à
son état précédent
toutefois les personnes âgées sont moins
flexibles et chez ces populations
on risque de ne pas voir ce retour à la
normale ça démontre aussi que la
solitude du à la pandémie est un
véritable risque biomédicale il y a
toutefois moyen de mitiger les impacts
sur le cerveau
[Musique]
les discussions à travers les médias
sociaux comme le clavardage ou le
partage des photos
ces choses là peuvent améliorer le
bien-être des gens une des choses les
plus efficaces que l'on peut faire en ce
moment et la vidéoconférence
il se passe quelque chose de spécial
lorsque l'on voit des visages humains
cela nous permet de se sentir connectés
d'une façon particulière pour pallier la
solitude jacob profite du présent pour
créer de nouveaux souvenirs
ces importantes documenter ce qu'on vit
ça fait ressortir cette résilience et ça
nous prouve au fait qu'on est capable de
s'adapter à n'importe quelle situation
même si elle est extrêmement pas naturel
pour un être extrêmement sociale qui a
besoin de sociabiliser
[Musique]
cette pandémie a révélé le poids de la
solitude sur nos neurones mais notre
cerveau n'a pas dit son dernier mot
[Musique]